just want to talk about what's happening
in Kiev to start with you you've been
haven't you yes so support
um key of refugees who are here yes I
was there almost exactly a year ago it
was the most beautiful city well I'm
sure it still is and it's just awful to
hear the news this morning we've got a
young woman who lives with us who's been
with us since March and she lives in
Kiev normally and has the Airaid siren
on her telephone which goes off in our
house and in my constituency in Banbury
and it's really chilling to hear the
news today actually and I thought for
those that are in Kiev at the moment yes
I'm zapparija overnight was attacked
again it is it is still you know we are
still in the absolute midst of war and
we've heard some Dreadful stories over
the weekend her grandparents are living
in their Cellar in Curson they come up
in the daytime but they sleep in the
cellar and they don't actually know
whether they voted or not in the recent
referendum a Russian soldier with a gun
came to the door and they filled in
papers but they what they meant they
don't know and it's it's quite solitary
I think for us to remember what is
actually happening at the moment how
appropriate was it do you think for the
destruction of the bridge that uh
connects uh Crimea and Russia because he
was always going to react to that well I
don't think the ukrainians have taken
responsibility for that destruction so
we have to be very careful I think
um we don't know who was responsible for
it in the Ukrainian mind
um that bridge was
quite an aggressive act in itself
because it linked Crimea to to Russia so
the ukrainians or certainly the ones who
we know don't like that bridge but I
don't think we know who was responsible
for blowing it up and he is speaking to
his security team this morning uh
President Putin he has threatened on
more than one occasion the prospect of a
nuclear attack what would you say to him
well I think
it's this is a really worrying time for
globally really I I'm sure that we in
this country have done the right thing
by the ukrainians both by taking them in
but also very importantly by supporting
them militarily it's absolutely right
that we should continue to stand with
the ukrainians against this Russian
aggression and I really hope that we can
de-escalate
uh one of the byproducts of uh the war
in Ukraine of course is the energy
Supply both through Europe and indeed to
the UK as well
um it's causing all sorts of problems
for people here in the United Kingdom
going forward especially going into the
winter why isn't the government uh
offering an advice campaign an ad
campaign to tell us what to do to try to
save energy
well it's something that we're thinking
about but at the moment we don't think
we need to spend a lot of public money
on a campaign like that the reason for
that is really that we are very lucky
particularly when you look at other
places in Europe which don't have the
security of energy Supply that we have
we're only about 20 percent reliant on
on the Imports of of gas in this country
so we're we're fairly secure the the
National Grid who advise on this have
said that we have a buffer and we're
pretty certain that we will have enough
energy to go through the winter I mean
certainly the environmentalist in me
says for goodness sake turn the lights
off when you leave a room and use energy
very carefully of course I do and that's
the way I've brought my children up to
behave and and that's the way that I
would hope people could be but I don't
think we need to frighten people and
what I'm really worried about is that
older people and vulnerable people do
need to put the heating on and need to
still able to do that so so we have to
get the balance right with the messaging
yeah pretty certain isn't definite
though is it I mean well I think in this
world very little is definite but the
the National Grid has said that we're
fairly secure we have a buffer and it's
very unlikely uh to use their words that
we won't have enough electricity this
winter but of course if if you're out
and about and you're not at home then of
course turn the heating down or off some
people can't afford to put it on in the
first place
um but if we're not concerned about it
unnecessarily then why are you advising
people not to use as much electricity
well that that's only for an
environmental point of view rather than
a rather than a security one the the
government is is
pretty confident that we have enough
energy to get us through this winter
we're feeling quite fortunate compared
with some of our European friends in
that regard and
we if if we need to give more messaging
later on in the winter then we'll do
that but at the moment what is important
is that we help people to understand
that there is enough energy they should
use it if they need it and if they're
old or vulnerable and sitting at home
then they should put the heating on of
course they should Nadeem zahawi who
describes himself as the Chief Operating
Officer for the government was on the TV
yesterday saying we should go to the
government website to look for advice I
went and I feel it actually it's not
straightforward and filled in quite a
lot of questions and the outcome was
that I needed to buy a 35 000 pound heat
pump
was it yes was this a was this a an
attempt to get you to be in more more
environmentally no idea but that's what
it was suggesting that I should do in
order to try to save energy but there
you go the 12 to 37 000 pounds depending
on the ground source and and went
further into it and it said about 35
grand for my heat pump well I mean
clearly that's not an option that's
available to everybody I mean it may be
I don't know how you answered the
questions or what sort of house you live
in but um we do need to look at new ways
and new Renewables to heat our
properties I don't have a heat pump I'm
still on oil I'm afraid so I think at
home we we will be a bit more sparing we
will be a bit more mindful but I've
tried for years to to get the children
to be more mindful about the energy they
use if I'm honest a lot of people
um are on benefits
um and would not be able to afford that
sort of money or indeed to put the
heating on at all over the winter period
and and yet the prime minister is
looking at or being told not increasing
benefits by the rate of inflation I'm
guessing you would implore to think
again on that well no decision has been
taken about the upbrating of benefits
this is a a it's quite a long and and
prostrate process driven decision-making
and and if I could just explain it to
you so tomorrow we'll get the September
figures I know it's October but they
come out tomorrow on earnings next week
we'll get the figures on inflation and
then the Secretary of State my secretary
of state at the department of work and
pensions has a statutory duty to
consider those figures you can't do
anything until those figures have come
and she will then consider how to if at
all upbrate benefits and what figure to
choose she has a very wide discretion to
do that we make a decision and we
communicate it usually by the end of
November and then I will take through a
piece of legislation in the House of
Commons which happens every year
um in January and then benefits will be
up up rated or not or in in accordance
with whatever method is chosen in April
but as if we know which we do according
to research that's been done if we don't
increase it by inflation benefits 450
000 more people will go into absolute
poverty I think it's a no-brainer I
think it's really important we have all
the statistics and all the figures about
poverty as well at our disposal before
we make this critically important
decision it's obviously a really
worrying time for people on benefits
because they know that inflation is
rising and they want us to make this
decision as soon as we possibly can so
that they have the security of knowing
how their benefits will be next year I
get that completely but I can't possibly
make the decision and on my own now we
need to get the figures get everything
at our disposal and then I will make
sure that we make that decision as
quickly as possible okay but it's going
to cost 5 billion pounds if you go with
inflation how will you pay for that I
think um the difference between between
the two figures wages or inflation is
about half of that in fact
um so but obviously it depends on what
those figures are but we'll know a lot
more next week is really important that
we make sure that we target the
government resources at the most
vulnerable this winter
um okay talk to me about the SMP if you
would it's their conference at the
moment in Aberdeen and Nicola sturgeon
says she detests everything the Tories
stand for how do you feel about her well
I don't think that's great language to
use and actually frankly when you look
at the global situation we're in and the
war that we were just talking about I
really think it's quite important that
we're able politely to disagree with
each other in this country we are so
fortunate we can have a democratic
system so much that we take for granted
and we ought to be able to have sensible
discussion about policy without
detesting each other there's no need
okay politics of the playground well I
it's just not how we do things I don't
think
um talk to me about some suggestions in
the newspapers this morning that I'm
reading that Tom Watson should be given
a period that was knocked back a couple
of years ago but sakiristama is looking
again at uh Tom Watson getting a period
what do you think well it's a matter for
the labor party who they put forward for
parentages
well I've never really I I'm I'm not the
world expert on that story I know that
there was there was well let me tell you
yeah yeah yeah he he um had been accused
um or he his he has now been Consulting
the victims of false sex abuse
allegations
um lady Britain as in um yeah his widow
branded Mr Watson despicable and
defensive as you know he was falsely
accused of rape and child abuse as a
result of this uh campaign that had been
conducted at the time
um Harvey Proctor falsely accused of
being a child murderer by this fantasist
as well supported by um Tom Watson
should he get a peerage well the my
difficulty is Kate is that I I don't
know what Tom Watson believed I don't
know I I'm really can't advocate for him
in any way he was clearly taken in by
somebody who was making up very
unpleasant and and malicious stories
about prominent men at the time what Tom
Watson believed at any one time I really
can't so you wouldn't it wasn't
something that you would say well I
think it's very important that anybody
who gets a period should be very
carefully investigated and I do think to
go to your earlier point that it is
quite important that we're very careful
in public life about who we accuse of
what yeah um so everybody should be
thoroughly investigated before they get
a period what about Conor Burns
I don't think there's any suggestion
that Conor Burns is getting a period
yeah there is yeah yeah there is
um yeah apparently um his name is on the
list that um the former prime minister
has put forward uh well I haven't heard
that what do you think should he get one
um I think where we are what's happened
I I don't know any more about that well
I probably know less about the facts of
the incident than you do I think what's
important is that the chief whip has
been asked to investigate this I think
that she must do that as quickly and as
thoroughly as possible it's a really
difficult situation for all involved not
least
um the the accuser the the victim the
alleged victim if you like and I think
it's really important that we we solve
um this particular problem as quickly as
we can before he gets the Knighthood
what is impressive is that the Prime
Minister took very Swift action she did
to make sure that that Conor was removed
from office while the matter is
investigated but I think from his point
of view as well as anybody else involved
we just need to get on with working out
what happened the young Ukrainian girl
that lives with you what's her name
thika okay well we have another Victoria
yeah we hope she's okay she's
um
it's
it's a great privilege having her to
stay actually
um but we do feel the war is very close
we must let you go thank you very much
indeed for joining us miss Presley thank
you